Jimmy Johnson I'll take this lead in
every time guys I appreciate it
how you feeling my friend I'm good man
oh well all right you have an eight-part
original docu-series goes behind the
scenes kind of place networks teamed up
with great filmmaker Peter Berg how did
you feel making race road to race day
did you feel like a Kardashian while you
were doing this and it premieres July
19th where can we see it you know it was
far more than just the time they spent
with me so I Drive it Hendrick
Motorsports and we have a four car
operation with chase Elliott
Dale Earnhardt jr. Kasey Kahne and
myself and then at Hendrick Motorsports
we have over 660 employees departments
like you wouldn't believe
and mr. Hendrick had this idea to really
show behind the scenes let us capture
the footage and then let us work on the
editing with Peter and his group after
that and really show a level behind the
scenes that's never been done before
so the docu-series goes through a
variety of races a variety of
experiences with the different team
members the different drivers on the
team and you get to get to see far more
than anything else it's kind of scary
honestly when I've seen my pieces um I
remember cameras being there but I
wasn't sure some of that would make it
to TV and down for that are you happy
with the series are you happy with the
way it turned out
yeah I totally am I feel that you know
that that raw emotion the
behind-the-scenes look and what really
goes into our sport not only I heard you
lead-in earlier not only am i an athlete
which would describe some of the
athletes that are on a road crew team
that mechanic on the race car that jump
over the wall and service conduct ops
and the culture that exists behind the
scenes our athletic facility our
coaching staff our engineering aspect
the engine department composite
Department the chassis department I mean
it just goes on and on it's it's a nice
look behind the scenes or what it takes
to be a competitive team of NASCAR I
think I'll blow everybody's mind well
Jimmy I know you're an athlete you're
great athlete you're one of the best
that's ever done it and
you're a seven-time champion that's not
even more than LeBron it's more than
Jordan and you guys put your life on the
line every single time you go in the car
within the last few years you've had a
couple of teammates retired jeff gordon
two years ago and dale jr. announced
that this is his last season where you
at with the rest of your career have you
thought about retirement yeah man I
guess I'm closer to it then I realized
then I just send it through your
extension with Hendrick Motorsports and
we'll be around for at least three more
I'm I feel like I'm doing a decent job
of balancing personal life and
professional life and more than anything
the fire still burns to compete to be
out there racing to be out there winning
races and competing for championships so
I've at least got three more in me but
yeah all of a sudden the elder statesman
at Hendrick Motorsports did you ever
think that you would be the the older
guy I guess everybody knows it's coming
you just went when you that reality hits
you in the face you're like oh wow it's
now like I haven't seen it coming then
all of a sudden boom there it is you
know NASCAR one of the things that's
crazy that I saw in this series road to
race day is NASCAR unlike any other
sport you guys are signing autographs
with fans in the garages that would be
like at halftime of a Dallas Cowboys
game the locker room is filled or or in
a practice field do you like the
interaction with fans are you able to
concentrate does it freak you out and it
is it may be are you guys concerned
about running over a fan you know it
honestly is one of the toughest parts of
the job we have such a condensed period
of time to work with their teams to
practice on track to be in that garage
area and unfortunately that's really the
only time the fans have a chance to see
us get an autograph and interact so with
that said they're there many times over
the course of a weekend but it with
polls on me and I'm like man I wish that
energy exchange was a heck of a lot
better but I'm about three minutes to
run through the transport of the car to
get buckled in practice is going to
start just in an engineering meeting you
know then when practice is over we've
got in some cases 20 minutes to get the
car turned around and why
for technical inspection for qualifying
so every second counts I've got to run
literally back to the transporter
debrief with the engineers make
decisions and as I'm in transit you know
there's a couple hundred fans that are
excited to see you and want an autograph
but you can't you know and so that
really does pull on me probably more
than any other aspect of the job I think
the true you know fans get it but it's
inevitable I do notice that it provide a
certain feeling falling away now listen
I was teasing earlier there there's
always an ongoing debate about if NASCAR
drivers are athletes you know I know I
Drive in Los Angeles traffic with one
hand on the wheel another hand on a
cheeseburger but you're the real deal
and I and I heard you you you know you
train hard I saw it on road to race day
you work out you're a triathlete you run
marathons you run up mountains you run
down mountains how does all of that
endurance training help you in the car
explain that to me because for the
cynics and I am cynical but I do every
respect you know what is it like to be
in the car and why do you train so hard
I mean you're a legitimate you know
Ironman outside the car well I mean I
think as you get older you know you
appreciate the situation you're in you
want to maximize your opportunity and
when early years to getting started my
training was much less you know I
suffered on Monday Tuesday just trying
to recover and get back in a swing of
things
so as I've evolved as an individual and
within my sport now the easiest thing I
do all week is my race on Sunday my
training farm or a tent so Monday and I
pop out of bed and I'm ready to start
training and rolling again and then
that's led to more knowledge on
nutrition hydration recovery rest you
know that the whole gamut that goes into
being an athlete so you know I feel like
you know there's some guys getting away
with a lot less but you know if you want
to come come race with me and try to
challenge me for seven championships I
think I've kind of set the bar and I
need to go about that I like that I like
the cockiness okay Jimmy Johnson because
I'm cocky and I appreciate the cockiness
now when you said you said you mentioned
earlier you just said
after Monday and Tuesday's after races
it was hard to recover when you were
racing take me inside the car recover
from what what besides because it seems
so mental it seems so bad about the
mental physically what is the toll that
a race takes on you what is it what is
it toll that a NASCAR race takes on you
if you're not in shape sure so for
starters we withstand 3 G's in the
corners which means why explain it to
that I told to us a half of a disabled
reading person like myself sure so
that's three times your body weight
three times the vehicle weight you know
three GS so you go into a turn and it
slams you into C so you know your arms
are up it's a lot of strain on your
shoulders on your core is a very big
part of that and also your legs trying
to hold your legs like the pedals and
work on all of that um the heat in the
car is a huge factor as times gone on
and the engineers learn how to make the
cars more efficient we are fueling the
cars off so that air doesn't get under
them and that just makes an oven where I
sit so we're seeing 130 degree cockpit
temps regularly NASCAR has picked up on
this and the television folks have and
they're putting thermometers in cars all
the time how to show that so how you
know you roll that into a four hour
routine you know I post all of my by
racing adventures and cycling stuff on a
app called Strava and I'd like to post
my heart rate and you'd be surprised to
see that you know I'm sitting there
upper aerobic lower anaerobic heart rate
for a four hour window driving the
racecar so I mean it's legit working
there alright so a cynic like myself if
I handed you the keys to the running
NASCAR okay not that I have any juice in
this community but if I handed you the
keys to running it to bringing new fans
what changes would you make to the sport
to attract new fans without alienating
the hardcore you know fans of NASCAR
that's the that's the tricky question I
mean would you say that was a great
question Jimmy honestly would you say
wow Michael Rapaport just threw me a
great question you crushed it man thank
you I appreciate that
there's
there's not one answer um you know it
not only has our sport evolved and we're
trying to keep up like many sports are
with their viewing audience you know
societies change the way people consume
anything has changed
I learned a phrase recently called the
cable cutters and that's people that
don't use a television any longer so
they don't have cable TV or satellite TV
they strictly download all their content
look at their news through social and
they're completely disconnected well
that unfortunately hurts sports it hurts
works a lot of it um you know ESPN's
having its troubles the the market is
changing the only thing that's been
holding somewhat steadies at the NFL um
the live sports in general is hanging on
but regular programming for televisions
in the tank sports is trending down in
general so it's it's a tough world out
there I don't I don't know what the
secret ingredient is you know and I'm
watching my sport and my team and
sponsors never just trying to figure it
out all right well Jimmy I appreciate it
if you haven't seen road to race day you
should check it out check it out it's
in-depth you might as well say it's like
the Hard Knocks are 24/7
of NASCAR they had the best of the best
Jimmie Johnson you could catch it on go
go go 90 I appreciate you taking the
time Jimmy I hope you didn't take me
seriously I know you're not just an
athlete you're one of the best ever do
it appreciate you calling into the Rich
Eisen show and I appreciate the
compliments that I didn't lead you on to
saying how great my questions were no I
appreciate it and this is the the best
interview I've ever had in the history
of interviews can we make sure that's
recorded so we play that for the rest
yeah I think we got that clip Jimmy
thank you for taking the time I
sincerely appreciate it my friend
appreciative and be well did you hear
what he said he said it was the greatest
question in the history of questions and
he said it was the best decide I get to
interviewed every single best interview
you you did it the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
isn't it amazing you can download an app
with your thumbprint you should download
our app with your thumbprint